hey this is pressure Locker if su runs
around the track twice and John runs
around the track four times more than su
how many times does John run around the
track this problem caused some confusion
after I was assigned to third graders
the teacher was marking one number as
the correct answer and a parent believed
another number was the correct answer
the problem was then posted online and
many people believed the correct answer
was a third number so what's the correct
answer in this video I'm going to
present three different ways to
interpret this problem and suggest what
is the correct answer
according to modern usage the heart of
the confusion is the phrase four times
more than typically this phrase refers
to multiplication times more means that
John runs around the track four times
more than the number of times that Sue
runs so we take four times two to get to
the answer of eight other people had a
different interpretation of this problem
they read this as saying John runs
around four times more as an addition so
if Sue runs around the track two times
John runs four more laps than Sue this
is four more times so the number of
times the John would run would be four
plus two which equals six the problem
with this interpretation is we usually
write more times when we're referring to
addition and when we have the phrase
times more we're usually referring to
multiplication there's a third way to
read this problem which would be
literally correct according to these
words on a strict grammatical basis
the literal version of this problem is
often used in terms of percentages times
more than would mean you should add that
number of times to the base so think
about this in terms of percentages 100
percent more than 2 is a total of 4 200%
more than 2 is a total of 6 300% more
than 2 is a total of 8 and 400 percent
more than 2 is a total of 10 so 400
percent more is the same thing as 4
times so having four times more advanced
ooh would mean 4 times 2 plus 2 which
would equal 10 times so this is an
interpretation that's literally correct
according to the way the sentence is
written
however in common usage four times more
is the phrase that's commonly written
for multiplication to mean four times
larger you'll see this in newspaper
every single day a more literal and
correct way to refer to multiplication
would be writing four times as much as
and you'll see that many writers use the
phrase times as much as to mean
multiplication it's a very strict way of
writing it so I would caution you
against using this literal
interpretation unless you see
percentages so in conclusion of these
three interpretations I would say the
correct answer is 8 because times more
usually refers to multiplication and
even times more than refers to
multiplication so if John runs 4 times
more than Sue the correct answer to this
problem would be he would run 4 times 2
which is 8 times around the track what
do you think the correct answer should
be let us know in the comments thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch around social media
pressure soccer and if you liked this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description